vivimos en un mundo de realidades
construidas nuestros pensamientos
actitudes y emociones son en gran parte
producto de la influencia de los demás
en ocasiones esa influencia son
conscientes pero muchas otras ocurren de
manera totalmente inconsciente
detenernos reflexionar y pensar en que
estamos fallando
hay realidades que no la podemos obviar
el 80% de ciudades latinoamericanas
viven en estado de informalidad falta de
acceso a servicios básicos vivienda y
oportunidades desiguales
así como hago yo ciudad satélite hoy
aquí con 150 mil habitantes donde se
hace evidente en su mayoría la
informalidad con un gran crecimiento
poblacional hacia las periferias
siendo parte del 85% de ciudades
satélites que existen en el ecuador
que necesitan adquirir una identidad
propia para dejar de ser dependientes de
estos centros urbanos mayores
volvamos a detenernos y a pensar que
estamos viendo mal en nuestro entorno
será caso y culpa y parte de nuestra
mejor virtud que es la tolerancia
realmente toleramos todo tanto así que
hasta le enviamos un pastel a nuestras
novias diciendo te amo porque te tolero
es increíble porque así sea que me
pegues igual te amo igual que toleró
entonces aceptamos los peores nada ya no
nos queda de otra
realmente
desde pequeños nos enseñan a tolerar a
medias que al final terminamos de
tolerar lo intolerable la tecnología va
avanzando
la ciencia comienza a avanzar
preguntémonos qué pasa con nuestras
aulas
porque siguen iguales a través del
tiempo
porque el sistema de enseñanza
no evoluciona realmente está en crisis
las universidades actualmente estamos en
crisis
cómo es posible que se enseña
arquitectura hace cientos de años y
vivamos en una ciudad en la cual sea
totalmente o no participe con su gente
falta de identidad total hacemos cosas
que no pertenecen a ningún sitio
miles de estudiantes graduados del años
con tesis que terminan en un cajón y
nunca se construyen entonces nos ponemos
a pensar cuenta el caso no nos están
enseñando pensar
es muy complicado de fundir este día del
pensar
porque esto grave abre una gran ventana
hacia la libertad hacia la creatividad
hacia la autonomía que no todo el mundo
está de acuerdo con eso ya muchos no les
conviene
entonces
nos hemos unido algunas oficinas
emergentes y hemos llegado a funcionar
casi como un virus
tratando de ver cuáles son las
problemáticas reales de la ciudad y
poder con propuestas alternativas
partiendo de lo pequeño desde lo
cotidiano desde lo básico poder ir
apostando totalmente a las generaciones
de red en ciudades invisibilizadas en
este caso
en este caso por ejemplo como bebo yo y
nos hacemos la primera pregunta como
punto de partida es posible que una
oficina de arquitectura sea un centro
cultural
bueno este nuestro oficina en babahoyo
junto con el colectivo urbano facto la
desarrollamos en este espacio
en el cual podemos establecer un diálogo
casi directo con la comunidad trabajando
y trabajando con materiales de la zona
con gente del sitio que podamos incluir
en estos procesos las manos nuestros
primeros objetivos dentro de esta sala
como traemos a la comunidad e integramos
la comunidad tenía una realidad mucho
más cercana al arte
dijimos bueno abramos nuestras puertas y
conectemos las con el cine con la música
y gestionamos el primer festival de arte
y emprendimiento llamado rueda blanca
invitando a artistas nacionales e
internacionales a que expongan su obra
de esta forma es una plataforma de
participación y relaciones que lo
privado se abra como punto de encuentro
y producción de arte
partiendo desde la misma pregunta que
siempre nos hacemos
cómo podemos mantener un poco de sacan a
partir del caos
este es un sector típico yo no
se le quería hacer un asadero de pollo
ser la propia la idea de la arquitectura
de antes en lanzándolo vernacular con la
temporalidad de la arquitectura actual
solamente era de poner un volumen muy
limpio muy básico no en todo este perfil
caótico una arquitectura que siempre
está en movimiento que esté con él que
esté conectada con nuestro ser que no
hable que no comunique que real para que
realmente sea como un efecto que es un
efecto multiplicador no que nos ayude a
que con poco podemos hacer mucho a sí
mismo como un sector de la ciudad en
desuso desde una caleta de shawarma
hasta un local mucho más establecido
se genera el primer dinamizador
comercial de la zona teniendo puntos
abiertos de conexión comercial y
realmente volviendo a esta idea de
apropiar cómo eran los negocios
ambulantes de antes que abrían sus
puertas y vendían así entonces no perder
esa idea utilizando materiales de la
misma zona como los palafitos estos
palafitos que se usan en las casas
periféricas que sirven para poder estar
sobre el agua y seguíamos con las
preguntas es posible que un edificio
privado sea público
una de las características principales
del arroyo como ciudad pequeña era esta
conexión directa con la calle y no
perderla nunca era uno de los
principales objetivos
un local
del restaurante de mariscos que decían
ok vivimos bajo de un sistema
de viviendas colectivas sociales en la
cual estaba totalmente todo abandonó el
centro tenía mucho problema de
inseguridad qué pasaría si conectamos o
que la cubierta sea la arquitectura del
lugar y el límite comienza a desaparecer
no
qué es realmente esto sea como un efecto
de que los
de los locales que estaban en desuso
comienzan a tener como esta autoestima
de poder volver a tener nuevas
oportunidades y actualmente ya hay
locales que están abriéndose
podríamos vivir en una casa de palets y
no morir en el intento
los arquitectos o las personas que no
son arquitectos debemos dejar de ser
gente de pensadores de escritorios
salir involucrarnos mucho más los
procesos participativos
pensar mucho más con las manos durante
el terremoto del 2016 junto a nuestros
grandes amigos gestores culturales
cronopios planteamos una vivienda
emergente productiva que sea realmente
un gran núcleo de la comunidad teniendo
un diálogo abierto
generando economía familiar enseñándole
a los chicos a tener sus propios
recursos a partir de micro huertos
urbanos darle la vuelta a la tortilla
era muy fácil teníamos 50 palets que
podíamos hacer con eso creamos una
vivienda que actualmente sigue en uso y
dejó de ser emergente
podría una casa de oración ser un
catalizador urbano
otra vez un sector típico de odio muy
vulnerable a la inseguridad teníamos una
casa en desuso que podíamos hacer con
esto necesitaban una casa de oración y
era utilizar todo lo que más se podía
se plantea una arquitectura totalmente
primera permeable que vaya conectando
está idea o este discurso de ser una
ciudad mucho más directa con el entorno
y con la calle
es ir experimentando con las estructuras
que pasa cuando tenemos un lugar de 10
metros de ancho y ya no necesitamos esas
vigas metálicas porque no ir rescatando
nuestra materialidad de antes teniendo
en cuenta que nuestras principales
personas para poder ayudar a construir
esto era la comunidad misma
desarrollando con los niños talleres
prácticas sostenibles que nos ayuden a
realmente a sostener esta idea de que la
comunidad es la que hace la arquitectura
nosotros somos intermediarios solamente
entonces a veces cuando nos hacemos esta
pregunta sin sentido y después salen o
se crean estas utopías reales nos hacen
preguntas como éstas es posible
construir un mirador invisible en las
montañas nos trasladamos hasta guapo
loma que son la montaña de los andes
junto a la comunidad cercana
había mucha casita alrededor los
invitamos a hacer partícipe de esta
intervención autogestionada que siempre
se hace en la oficina
aquí vamos a hacer un mirador
en la cual dormimos tres días con la
gente del sector con nuestros amigos
colaboradores
lo llamamos el portal invisible
realmente la idea inicial nace a partir
de conectar al ser humano con la
naturaleza de una forma muy directa que
tú llegues y digas ok estoy yo aquí a
través de los espejos reflexiones con tu
yo interior y qué es lo que tienes es tu
entorno es como abrir una puerta y ver y
descubrir lo que siempre haya estado ahí
que sea como una excusa perfecta para
que puedan lograr conectarte con lo que
realmente yo digo no es nuestro origen
este sector se llama las nubes
encantadas es porque siempre va
ascendiendo
como cuando hervimos la leche no sube la
espuma y nosotros parecemos que
estuviéramos flotando en el cielo luego
de un año de su construcción
la intervención ahorita es un punto de
referente nacional turístico que mucha
gente va los fines de semana y la
comunidad en su entorno ya salen a
vender tortillas y generan una economía
familiar
entonces llegamos casi a la conclusión
de que la arquitectura también podemos
definir redefinir nuestro modo de
habitar y nuestro modo de hacer las
cosas
una casa del miduvi que bueno es el
ministerio de desarrollo urbano y
vivienda dentro del centro del centro de
la ciudad que nos permite a nosotros ir
explorando y redefiniendo todas estas
cuestionamientos sobre vivienda
definieron espacio de vivienda en
crecimiento que tenga un negocio propio
que se pueda ampliar al futuro
y que realmente sea
un tema muy básico que cumpla con la
inseguridad de la zona era totalmente
los requisitos de dos profesores que
apostaron por el diseño
juntamos mil bloques cuadrados de
arcilla
hecho por los ladrilleros de la vuelta
de la casa
vemos y otra vez a incitar a reflexionar
una arquitectura que nos permita ver y
no olvidarnos de conectarnos siempre con
la ciudad
permitir la consistencia que pasa cuando
yo tengo 10.000 dólares para remodelar
una casa y la casa de al lado costo lo
mismo es decir cómo podemos nosotros
tener esta visión de arquitectura hoy de
hacer mucho con poco
ahorita la naturaleza ser la propia del
sector y este árbol ya es un núcleo no
desde el patio asimismo cómo vivir entre
bloques ese pongamos no pensar que si
somos como voy a vivir entre bloques
siempre siempre apostamos por no tener
dinero cuando tú vas con el cliente
la falta de presupuesto es el objetivo
qué pasa cuando tú tomas un bloque eso
para hacer las losas y comienzas a
generar un nuevo hábitat comienza a
generar los nuevos envolvente comienza
vamos a comenzamos a experimentar formas
de habitar entre el material visto no
dentro de un
tiempo este esta casa comienza y
comienza a abrirse como un punto de
producción hacia lo cultural hacia el
arte entonces nos recordamos la idea de
cuando hicimos el taller el tallercito y
lo planteamos como un punto de gestión
cultural comienza en estos espacios
privados también a tener punto comienzan
a generarse de estas redes de
intercambio entonces y uno se pregunta
cómo vivirá este individuo porque vive
aquí
[Música]
oscar mora
d
en casas del exterior
dentro de mi casa entonces cada vez que
viene personas nuevas y conoce y me
preguntan y se cuestionan si es que no
tengo miedo de vivir así con un paso muy
abierto las personas por el contrario lo
que buscan es proteger y crear muros
cuidar todos muy cerrados para proteger
sus cosas no es un espacio entonces con
esta propuesta de alguna forma se rompe
ese modelo y se crea espacios más
abiertos cada vez que tomo mi bicicleta
salgo con la ciudad a dar vueltas y ver
en nuevas propuestas interesantes de
arquitectura para mí eso es alentador y
creo que
el buen camino con lo que está haciendo
ahora
[Música]
nos quedan más preguntas por resolver
que esto solo sea el principio por más
estudiantes que se cuestionen por más
arquitectos que se arriesguen formar
gente que crea que lo diferente pueda
ser posible vivimos en un mundo de
realidades construidas sigamos
construyendo realidades juntos gracias
[Aplausos]